alors il eu un clash
les traîtres entre delphine et n'a tout
art et moi j'étais venir à celle et
franchement elle s'était enroulé de la
ville et de la non mais dis moi aussi
j'ai amené mes copains aussi avec moi et
je me fais une émission jamais la mine
comme l a mené une copine je l'aimé bien
elle était venue dans l'émission de ça
mais là une belle fille n'a été un
delphine c'est chaud noël si vous
regardez regardez le classement j'étais
comme ça quoi
je trouve
sèche et agressive
je trouve ça totalement injuste
totalement gratuit alors justement
contrairement à toi j'ai pas l'habitude
de jouer la comédie
j'ai plus rien à dire
c'est trop pour moi
[Applaudissements]
ces émissions même si c'est ça les stars
vraie danse avec les stars on verrait
jamais de star en train de se clasher
maintenant ils voient comme elles sont
dans la vraie vie c'est ça qui les forme
si fort d'un fine
oui en fait le premier jour quand je
suis arrivé je me suis dis parce que je
connaissais pas trop je me suis dit ça
va vraiment être ma copine en plus j'ai
vraiment téléphone et mon agent j'ai dit
il ya une super nana est ma copine sénat
tout et tout et elle m'a pris en grippe
je ne sais pas pourquoi des sciences en
fait elle ne l est à dire le pollen
quotas c'est que les mof
tenir jg rien fait et en fait le truc
c'est que vu que je pensais que sa
copine donc mais le coco étaient
traîtres du coup en m'attaquant am
locaux qu elle a défendu sa copine donc
en fait j'en avais 2 contre moi et vu
que m locaux c'est vrai personne ou
c'est
de mélo coop on a parfois nous les rêves
merci que les deux filles étaient toutes
en permanence avec bruno et avec alex en
fait tu t'attaques r une personne temps
avec 4 sur le dos l'équipe obama mais
très vite je me suis fait éliminer non
jeu aussi c'est justement sa stratégie
gérald où les groupes qui s'enchaînaient
sans jeu remis les coupes et moi
j'aurais mis des coups de pression là
bas ah oui comment vous arrivera jeudi
écoute moi bien je t'explique l'a vérif
public tout de suite tu votes pour moi
tu finis dans un coffre
j'ai dit que c'est même pas la peine je
t'explique jeter encore une fois dire
mon nouveau tournant mais je les attends
les bras comme ça j'ai jamais de début
d'année unis qui commence dans les bois
qui sort en temps une fois mon one ou
nas un trade
à
dire tu vas voir c'est qu'un grand raid
et moi j'ai envie de le faire le jeu
juste pour ça
nancy on va entendre mon nom cyrill pas
du tout c'est
non mais c'est vrai non mais attends ça
va la situation je vais vous dire on est
obligé de tricher aujourd'hui dans le
monde dans lequel on me
regarde et on regarde octobre la table
mais est ce qu'on vous a proposé d'être
loyal d'en être ou est ce qu'on vous a
imposé une imposé alors effectivement ça
a été imposé mais quand même ils nous
ont posé la question juste avant le jeu
là bas j'ai tout le monde et on voulait
dire actuellement deux personnes mais
tout le monde voulait très bas oui bah
c'était un prix deux ont pris leur
décision en fonction des caractères des
personnages est sûre les gens veulent
être être ali ben quand tu fais un jeu
comme semblait wyatt unis comme au
meilleur des cas comme gilles verdez
c'est vrai j'ai envie contrairement à ce
que tu fasses finalement d'être loyal
c'est plus intéressant dans le jeu parce
que les prêtres sont vraiment chassé en
permanence les écrivains ont pu se
traite les traitent ils vont et viennent
te réveiller la nuit pour taillefer des
réunions moi je suis très très bas par
rapport à nico mucke
bout quoi bien très meilhon est une
réunion et que les deux open mais qu'est
ce que c'est mon pote istèque en fait
jean miche mamba veilleux qui s'en fait
ch en train de dormir frère non mais
sont fous sera très raide et stratégie
mais quelle stratégie qui ferment leur
gueule